la libération de maurice papon pour
raisons de santé sa volonté de faire
casser son procès est d'obtenir sa
réhabilitation
tout le monde en parle mais ce soir pour
en savoir plus nous avons décidé
d'inviter l'homme de l'ombre celui qui a
aidé papon à fuir en suisse il ya trois
ans et qui depuis se bat pour celui
qu'il estime innocent voici hubert de
beaufort
[Musique]
g
il
[Musique]
hubert de beaufort bonsoir bonsoir vous
êtes économiste spécialiste en
géopolitique vous avez 73 ans et vous
êtes le fils de guy de beaufort qui
était chef du cabinet militaire du
général de gaulle en 1958 c'est vrai
votre père a été le seul homme rescapé
d'une famille qui durant l'occupation
s'est illustré par une résistance
héroïque et a payé un lourd tribut à la
guerre
trois oncles résistants ont été fusillés
ou déportés et deux beaux frères de
votre père sont morts au combat
laissez-vous du maire de beaufort qui
aujourd'hui osé affirmer au sujet de la
révision du procès de maurice papon
papon c'est dreyfus oui sans vouloir
faire des comparutions abusives les
concepts fallacieux qui ont entouré le
droit on retrouve à peu près les mêmes
la même méthodologie et et une pression
médiatique intense le pour sensibiliser
en disant regardez cet homme affreux qui
apparaît par exemple des portes et des
enfants ce qui est à plumes on tape sur
deux est par conséquent on va par voilà
on va pas refaire ici ce soir le procès
de de maurice papon qui a eu lieu il a
été condamné complicité de crime contre
l'humanité
s'allumant donc va pas le refaire ici ce
soir votre père était proche du général
de gaulle
mais justement si vous voulez si j'ai
commencé à m'occuper de cette affaire
c'est que si vous voulez la famille
avait avait pu juger la façon dont
s'était passé les événements à plusieurs
niveaux d'abord il ya bien sûr mon père
qui était donc un des fondateurs de
laura et qui en 58 et des chef du
cabinet du général de gaulle et à ce
titre comme chef de cabinet il avait été
chargé de regarder les dossiers des
principaux collaborateurs du général
dont celui de maurice papon bien entendu
et il était clair qu aux yeux du général
de gaulle le dossier de papon
était un dossier qui ne prêtait pas à
contestation alors papon a toujours tenu
à se donner une image d'homme digne et
courageux alors pourquoi il ya trois ans
at il fui en suisse avec d'agen et fuit
il n'a jamais fui je veux dire que
j'aurais jamais je n'aurais jamais aidé
un cours d'année à fuir il savait que la
cour de cassation allait se mettre en
faute et la preuve en est c'est que il y
a trois mois la cour européenne de
strasbourg a condamné la france pour
procès inéquitable
de ce fait à partir du moment où la cour
de cassation allait commettre un impair
évident une faute ce que voulait pas
poncet rechercher un appui auprès d'une
autre autorité plus élevée que la nôtre
qui était la cour européenne
et pour cela il fallait voir les les
avocats internationaux de genève pour
travailler le dossier est il
il s'est installé un stade pour suivre
cette instruction du dossier c'est comme
ça que ça s'est passé alors à son retour
de suisse papon est incarcéré à la santé
dans ce qu'on appelle le carré viiip et
là ils rencontrent quelqu'un qui lui
aussi rentrer de cavale quelqu'un qui
aujourd'hui peut témoigner de l'état de
santé du prisonnier papon voici didier
schuller
[Musique]
g
mais schuller bonsoir donc quand vous
quittez saint domingue pour paris vous
dites à votre compagne christel delaval
s'il me mette en prison j'ai des chances
de me retrouver nez à nez avec papon et
quelques jours plus tard effectivement
vous prenez une douche avec maurice
papon à la prison de la santé dans quel
état est est il physiquement très
fatigué je reste un homme de 92 ans et
ce qui était assez impressionnant c'est
l'état de ses jambes
il ya des gens extrêmement gonflé il a d
oedème aux jambes il a de grandes
difficultés à marcher
nous l'avons un jour emmener en
promenade
je crois que c'était la première
promenade qu'il faisait depuis un an est
en fait on l'a fait porter par il y
avait un policier qui était également
détenu et c'est ce policier qui lui a
permis de descendre la promenade il
n'avait pas la capacité de descendre les
marches de l'escalier donc ça s'est
arrangé puisque là il est sorti de
prison
sur ses deux jambes n'ont pas faim oui
je veux dire il est capable de faire
jusqu'à s'il n'ya pas d'escalier il est
capable de faire 100 m ouais c'est tout
alors didier schuller vous vous
connaissiez en fait maurice papon vous
aviez chasser l'oie sauvage en écosse
chez la princesse de kent avec lui vous
êtes bonnes relations avec lui malgré
nos résultats ces jeux les jeux les
connu quand il était ministre
et puis je l'avais connue avant quand il
était un des dirigeants de l'ue des airs
pour moi personnellement papon c'est
quelqu'un qui a participé au régime de
vichy le régime de vichy a fait des lois
qui sont des lois ignoble qui étaient
des lois antijuives le régime de régime
de vichy a collaboré avec les allemands
et les fonctionnaires de vichy tous les
fonctionnaires de vichy y compris les
magistrats et c'est tout le monde à
collaborer et à participer à cette
politique antijuive quelques petites
monstrueuse maurice papon était un de
ses fonctionnaires simplement un de ses
fonctionnaires et en plus il était
secrétaire général de la gironde
il n'était ni premier ministre s'était
pas pierre laval c'était pas le maréchal
pétain
ça n'était pas non plus monsieur
bousquet monsieur bousquet ni même le
dollar pourquoi pourquoi didier schuller
lorsque vous rencontrez maurice papon à
la prison de la santé pour la première
fois vous lui dites d'entrée vous savez
ma mère est juive
j'ai voulu lui expliquer que
personnellement je n'oublie pas et je ne
pardonne pas et je ne pardonne pas à
maurice papon fonctionnaire de vichy
d'avoir commis les actes qu'il a commis
comme fauteur de vichy au niveau de
l'histoire et papon ça n'est pas pétain
7,1 des six ans sous préfet qui ont fait
le sale boulot de vichy ça n'est rien
d'autre soixante ans plus tard le juger
dans les conditions qui ont été celles
de bordeaux ritoo jeu
je m'interroge donc vous êtes de la vie
de badinter qui comme vous d'ailleurs a
perdu beaucoup de membres de sa famille
dans les camps de l'extermination vous
considérez que la détention de papon est
inutile mais vous lui reprochez quand
même ses maladresses cours due au cours
du procès de bordeaux
quand vous lui parlez à papon
il vous dit j'attends la décision de la
cour européenne des droits de l'homme
oui ce père qui bat il m'a dit moi je
n'attends aucune mesure de grâce de la
part du président de la république
la seule décision qui m'intéresse c'est
la décision de la cour européenne des
droits de l'homme
il vous a parlé de chirac oui oui vous
avez quoi bon il a il a participé
certainement en tant que trésorier du dr
a pas mal de financement et je pense que
tous tous les hommes politiques
importants de l'ue des airs de l'époque
devaient défiler dans son bureau il est
certain que le président de la
république a dû défiler dans son bureau
rue à part ça pourquoi papon avait une
cellule de 20 mètres carrés alors que
les autres avaient le tiers de sa non
pas du tout en général il ya deux
détenus par par cellule papon alfred
sirven et crozemarie étaient seuls dans
leur cellule ils étaient mieux traités
que les autres papas présents
non je veux dire que tout le monde tout
le monde est traité exactement de la
même manière si vous avez un peu
d'argent personnel vous pouvez acheter
20 la cantine ouais petit j'ai un petit
très curieux cette cantine les plats qui
sont servis par la cantine sont des
plats qui sont casher pourquoi il avait
un vrai oreiller pape en est pas un bloc
de mousse comme les autres je pense que
quand on a 92 ans je vais vous dire le
fond d'affaires il est là les prisons
françaises ne sont pas fait je vous
parle pas des présidences française et
je me demande pourquoi patron avait un
oreiller quand on entend des sons des
petits blocs de mousse pourquoi il avait
une sonnette pour appeler la sq il
aurait nui à son bord ils étaient les
seuls à être traité comme ça je sais
c'est 2007 parce qu'il avait été préfet
de police peut être parce qu'il avait
technicien avait quatre ans que j'essaie
de comprendre il ya d'autres gens
monsieur quand 92 j'essaie de vous étiez
avec la lune tout à fait c'est de
comprendre je pense que s'il avait une
seule est c'est parce qu'il est un état
de santé qui était effectivement
préoccupant est que l'administration
pénitentiaire ne voulait peut-être pas
avoir la responsabilité de l'avoir
laissée mourir dans sa cellule
dire qu'en france pays des droits de
l'homme maintenant en détention ce soit
papon que ce soit d'autres détenus ou
maintenant en détention
des hommes qui n'ont pas la capacité
physique d'être en détention et ça c'est
un problème qui est extrêmement grave et
qui t'apprennent de droits de l'homme de
respect des droits de l'homme enfin
papon et c'est quand même une heure de
marche tous les jours non non ça dépend
des jours franchement faut écouter moi
je suis resté 24 jours à ses côtés il ya
des jours où il resté couché de tout de
toute la journée dans sa cellule il ya
des jours effectivement où il marchait
long couloir penser qu'il est sorti deux
bouts pour montrer qu'il est en bonne
santé
non il est monté il est il est sorti de
boue par dignité tout simplement je
crois que c'est un homme
je crois que mon voisin ne niera pas ce
que je dis qu'il ya une très forte
énergie et une volonté de de ne pas de
ne pas paraître une épave
or alors que physiquement je crois que
la vérité a été dit sur son état médical
son 2ème des jambes
laurent laurent pratiquement un peu de
temps c'est espérons que cela pourra
attirer l'attention sur les militants
d'action directe qui sont toujours
emprisonnés et surtout les malades du
sida qui sont emprisonnés ceux qui
sortent d'un cancer incurable et on
pourrait s'occuper maintenant oui alors
après la libération de maurice papon on
aurait pu en rester là il aurait pu
choisir de se taire et de se soigner
mais non à peine dehors ses avocats et
vous donc hubert de beaufort vous parlez
de révision du procès et même de
réhabilitation tout à fait je veux dire
on m'a chargé de quoi moi je ne
connaissais pas papon avant son procès
ce sont les organisations gaulliste qui
m'ont demandé d'effectuer une contre
enquête
cette contre enquête démontre que pape
on ne peut pas être coupable de ce dont
on l'accuse c'est à dire de complicité
de crimes contre l'humanité on verra si
un autre procès en tous les cas en
entendant parler d'un nouveau procès il
ya quelqu'un qui a pris ça comme une
insulte à la mémoire du peuple juif
c'est julien dray il est là
[Musique]
g
bonsoir bonsoir alors julien dray
contrairement à didier schuller vous
êtes contre la libération de norris
papon maintenant il est libéré mais
quand beaufort parle de révision du
procès vous entendez révisionnisme oui
bah moi je vais d'abord vous dire que ça
ne passe pas parce que maurice papon n'a
pas eu un seul mot à la mémoire de ces
victimes pas un acte de contrition
pas un regard il faudrait un sentiment
de charité faudrait s'il était coupable
parce que pendant que lui était préfet
de la république
d'autres étaient résistants et d'autres
mouret sous la torture
et eux mérité le respect alors comment l
expliquez vous comment expliquez vous
que jean françois se tenait qui est juif
comme vous dont le père et moi je suis
là en tant que député la république pas
en tant que juif d'accord bon d'accord
je suis content a été de l'arrivée et en
tant que citoyen français il n'ya pas
des juifs et des non juifs et l'on peut
aussi vous voulez je pense que la
libération de paris jean finirait par là
parce que c'est pas un sujet de
polémique la libération de papon c'est
une insulte à la mémoire non pas des
juifs et non juifs à la mémoire de tous
ceux qui n'ont pas baissé la tête et qui
dès 1940 ont commencé à résister à lavau
permettait de vos listes qu'elle
consomme
bien sûr on peut parler on va pas
refaire le procès de maurice non mais je
voudrais qu'ils allaient l'attaquer
devant l'attenté de jeu devant vous je
voudrais vous lire quelque chose vous
pouvez me lire tout ce que vous voulez
là bas je vais vous le dire mais il ya
toujours jeu c'est de la théorie des
révisionnistes c'est tout c'est moi
intérêts de la théorie du signal
c'est toujours ce désir de voir écouter
là je reconnais la shoah comme vous un
non mais c'est pas le problème le
problème c'est que la justice française
elle a rendu un jugement qui a considéré
que maurice papon était coupable
bon d'accord elle l'a fait après impôts
c'est un procès équitable où il a pu se
défendre
ce que d'autres n'ont pas pu faire voilà
la réalité c'est tout point à la ligne
alors aujourd'hui monsieur pape on nous
a refait le coup de pioche et il était
dans un fauteuil roulant puis quand il
sort up
il est debout jacques aurez le plaisir d
hermès est plongée non je vais pas en
sortir 17 enfants juifs sauvés le 17 mai
43 grâce à maurice papon écouter un
extraordinaire sauvetage d'enfants juifs
fut rendu possible grâce aux mesures
prises par maurice papon après le
bombardement du 17 mai 43 à bordeaux une
assistante sociale de la préfecture ait
dit ses réseaux elles résistantes
protestante tenta une initiative
remarquable en vue de sauver 17 ans 19
enfants de la déportation le 15 juin 43
après un raid meurtrier de l'aviation
anglaise qui fit 350 morts dépose à la
demande suivante auprès de la préfecture
de bordeaux
monsieur le préfet je leur de solliciter
de votre haute bienveillance
l'autorisation de changement provisoire
de résidence pour les enfants israélite
dont les ensuite ça a été suivi par
maurice papon qui a obtenu la libération
des 19 enfants qui ont été sauvées et
alors puis je vous lire on les disait
vous le permettez j'écarte mot à dire
l'ensemble de ces témoignages ont été
fournies au cours du procès donc la
justice de notre pays
ah oui je reconnais a eu ces éléments là
mais vous savez les hauts fonctionnaires
de l'époque ils avaient tous
il avait 11 ans quand mon dealer bon
juif un ou leurs bons résistant et vous
savez moi c'est un very il fallait j'ai
dit car au mot j'ai à dire qu'un
les quatre mots les quatre premiers qui
ont été sauvés il s'appelait comment dre
david drai léon dre jacqueline et vous
voulez créer michel alaux et vous voulez
quoi je voulais vous dire que c'est que
que et vous savez que vous savez qu'il
ya des digues des milliers de drake
tombeau qui s'endort blick pas qu'ils
sont partis en virée grave grâce aux
autorités françaises oui selon goal est
sauvé grâce aux rites fois ce qu'il
fallait mais le problème n'est pas là le
havrais psychiatrique il ya 1600 enfants
et familles qui sont parties dans des
wagons plombés et qu'un préfet de la
république qui a organisé ces raf qui a
donné les ordres qu'ils savaient ce qui
allait se passer
voilà la réalité alors qu'après on
essaye de se racheter une conduite en
essayant de retrouver de ci de là des
services qu'on a fait tout le monde a
fait ça à la libération vous savez dans
tous les procès tous ceux qui étaient
dans les bottes avec toujours une excuse
il avait toujours un résistant qu'il
avait protégé une famille qu'ils avaient
sauvé et qui essayait d'être l'heureux
sauf conduit par rapport à la réalité
monsieur pape on savait il savait ce qui
allait se passer le savez pas vous savez
ce qu'il se passait au liban fut
collaborer avec les ramener alain jamet
collard elle le vrai problème jamais
collab le vrai problème à monsieur dray
c'est que malheureusement le corps
préfectoral tout le corps préfectoral en
français ben oui son jean moulin qui est
mort en martyr
mais le corps préfectoral dans son
ensemble à collaborer et à la libération
on a gardé une grande partie de ce corps
préfectoral c'est bien là le problème
papon on a trouvé 60 ans plus tard ce
qu'il avait fait c'est parce que nous on
a fabriqué mais c'est cette envie cette
merveille serait décevant ne va pas non
mais c'est sur ces deux réseaux miady
violeur qui sont en liberté d'un homme
est retrouvé l'or dans l'armée on doit
pas faire mais ce que je veux dire ce
que je veux dire c'est que à travers
papon on a peut-être voulu essayer de ce
je dirais de se purger ça c'est autre
chose même si le vrai problème
le premier président de la république
qui a le courage
après françois mitterrand qui lui
pendant la guerre n'a pas été très clair
vous le savez très bien quand même et
l'on risque serait le premier président
de la république quel courage de
reconnaître la responsabilité la faute
la faute cg régime en chien comme ak
conséquence et ça c'est le beaufort
pense que c'est cela qui a permis le
procès pas c'est gratuit
c'est jacques yeux sinon il faut le
reste c'est qu'il faut avoir le courage
de reconnaître que l'ensemble de
l'administration française et ses
personnages signé sous la contrainte des
problèmes c'est pas bon le problème
c'est que papon a été jugé bon
maintenant la sortie pour des raisons
médicales bon les gens et là qui sont
d'accord ils ne sont pas d'accord
globalement on dit les vieilles sort
mais maintenant il veut une
réhabilitation de yves une révision du
procès ça c'est ça qui demandent
toujours pas par dans l'armée vous tout
à fait monsieur de beaufort nous dit
c'est dreyfus donc avoué c'est pas mal
non c'est par ici des agréments
lisez la soirée aussi avec ce que je ne
comprends pas franchement je lui ai posé
la question en prison je vous la pose
ici ce soir faisait là pourquoi ne
demande pas pardon pour les avoir mais
enfin des actes qu'il a commis comme
fonctionnaire il n'a pas commis il est
tout ce qu'il a essayé pendant qu'il
était à il était à bordeaux c'est
d'essayer de limiter alors de limiter au
maximum après ça c'est trop facile 6 ans
et 5 à ce moment ça c'est exactement la
théorie du maréchal pétain
dès 1940 d'un certain nombre de
fonctionnaires qui étaient avec lui en
disant nous faisons cela pour attendre
le moment où les américains viendront
l'histoire il a fallu attendre 1972 le
livre de monsieur paxton pour voir à
travers les documents qui ont été
révélés que tout ça n'était que du
discours que la vérité c'est que les
autorités de vichy avait partie liée
avec la commandante urru laquelle
n'était en rien résistantes au contraire
qu'elle était totalement partie prenante
de l'idée d'une europe allemande sous
domination allemande et dans laquelle
les autorités françaises est forte ici
pécoste validé au c'est totalement faux
c'est moi marteau de ma famille a été
toute ma famille a été résistante et
fusillé alors je vous en ai tout de même
je sais ce que c'est que la résistance 1
dans la famille sont celles beaucoup sql
sql est demandé est ce que vous pouvez
demander à maurice papon de moi de
demander pardon demandé pardon de quoi
de ce qu'il a fait ce qu'il a fait mais
il n'a pas inna inapte ina il n'a jamais
commis d'acte autre que d'essayer de
faire ce qu'ils pouvaient faire mais je
vais vous dire monsieur monsieur papon
quand il le ce rende compte qu'on
enferme des femmes et des enfants des
les vagues dans des wagons tombés
quand il voit les tortures parce qu'il
le sait parce que les policiers les
raconte
que subissent les résistants quand ils
voient cette situation c'est un homme
libre il peut s'en aller
il peut démissionner mais il peut
apprendre est il n'a pas démissionné
parce que quoi mais parce que l'église
est il un problème avec sa conscience
les ont justement comme vous dites si
elle ne peut pas supporter ça dit de
faire comme d'autres c'est la rentrée en
détestant vous posez voulait pas rentrer
en résistance
mais parce que le général de gaulle a
demandé aux fonctionnaires de rester sur
place
ah non le gynécée gaulle il a sondé à
résister contre le métal - usa c'est à
dire la saboter c'est à dire à prendre
des risques où ils sont les fils et a
pris le relais mais on a pris tous les
jours ça mais champagne avec la commande
en tueur alors non messieurs les faits
ridicule mais votre le vous avez été un
collaborateur 9 françois mitterrand je
pas été un collaborateur est un ami de
l'anem mitterrand cela me taire et j'en
suis fier
françois mais j'ai pu disputer un géant
français et est autre chose vous savez
comme dans ses comptes au dossier via
conscience de ce dont c'était la
consigne était donnée un certain nombre
de hauts fonctionnaires
c'était d'organiser la résistance à
l'intérieur oui il ya eu et il y à une
bulle mais monsieur papa on n'avait
aucune n'y a aucun réseau de résistance
qui est venu dire monsieur maurice papon
a participé à la limite je vais même
aller plus loin on peut comprendre
qu'entre 40 et 41 ou 42 un certain
nombre de hauts fonctionnaires peuvent
être je dirais séduit par le discours de
pétain en dix ans on a protégé une
partie de la france on attend il y aura
qu nouvelle mais à partir de 42 tout le
monde c'est la réalité
tout le monde peut prendre ses
responsabilités en tant il les a pas
prises si la brise mais non il y aurait
les abruzzes
il les a pris la folie françois
mitterrand quant à mitterrand est arrivé
que les balises allemand monsieur
monsieur dray wallace et ses complices
est un bon fort qui a fait partir
mitterrand qui a fait partie à
mitterrand en angleterre oui alain de
beaufort qui a été fusillé par la
gestapo en 44 bon je dis simplement que
tout le raisonnement d'alan beaufort
auprès de françois mitterrand est la
raison pour lequel françois mitterrand
est partie site à ses câlins de beaufort
vous les persuader mitterrand dû rester
parce que les ans les les instructions
du général de gaulle c'était respect
qu'elle nageait finir quand même pas
nous expliquer que papon est un grand
résistant donc c'est quand même pas là
mais je ne dis pas qui est un grand
récit
je dis qu'il a il a il a résisté dans la
mesure où il pouvait résister à bordeaux
avait fait un livre blanc hubert de
beaufort vous a envoyé un certain nombre
de personnalités vous avez eu des
réponses de yves guéna de raymond barre
de l'amiral de gaulle qui vous ont dit
être choqué par ce procès qui a été fait
donc mais juste comme ça plus que ça
gainey a dit par exemple que le procès
papon était le procès contre de gaulle
j'ai lu votre livre blanc alors et je me
demande si ce qui vous motive
finalement c'est pas tout simplement le
bon vieil antisémitisme français
non j'ai été administrateur d'une banque
bus pendant 10 ans ce qui est rare parce
que c'est qu'une bande libre abbassi
c'est quoi une bande lui pour vous et
battu une banque ou les viandes de juifs
français milite pas d'accord parce qu'il
ya des gens parce que des gens qui sont
d'origine israël dans une banque la
banque de genband juive mais quand ils
sont juifs
ils ont mis la banque délicieux 10 qui
circulent par exemple y avait 350
députés juifs à l'assemblée nationale
l'assemblée nationale sur une assemblée
juive
nous avons élevé des recoins mais qu'en
est il quand ils ont ils travaillent
dans les organisations jeunesse à se
dire je pense que tous les
téléspectatrices et téléspectateurs
si ce n'est pas une crise s'il vous
plaît s'il vous plaît pas de 169 devenir
livre blanc allégi vous dites dans le
cas de la shoah
il s'agit de la placer comme pilier de
la deuxième guerre mondiale
oui voudraient que ce soit quoi un
détail non mais non c'est un drame
épouvantable
lachor par 2,6 millions de morts oui
c'est oui c'est un drame épouvantable
grand-mère harry de l'histoire du site
et je veux simplement dire que ça leur
demande barbarie de l'histoire de
l'humanité tout à fait parce qu'il n'ya
doute là dans toute l'histoire de
l'humanité il n'y a jamais eu une
planification six multi fiq visant à
distribuer la destruction systématique
des pins des enfants d'une histoire de
la mémoire et pas simplement au cours
d'un épisode c'est une volonté planifiée
organisée c'est pour ça lui manque que
la shoah dans l'histoire de l'humanité à
un trait particulier qu'on peut pas
ramener tous les massacres qui ont lieu
aujourd'hui encore et qui ont lieu tout
au long de ces siècles sur le même plan
parce que jamais les hommes non
organisée de manière aussi précise aussi
systématique avec autant de violence
autant de détermination
la destruction accord oui voilà et ce
alors
car ça c'est clair alors ils n'ont pas
donné aux élus tout ce que je veux dire
'attendez matin jeudi de moqueries au
aux yeux des grands dirigeants que ce
qu'était roosevelt staline churchill et
de gaulle
je dis simplement que là le problème
juif n'a jamais été un problème central
pour eux c'était gagné la guerre et ils
vous il ne vous il ne voulait pas que ce
soit mis en avant même lorsque il aurait
pu prendre un certain nombre de mesures
qui auraient limité
vous le savez très bien jeune et jeudi
temps libre au delà même si vous n'êtes
pas écrit ce que set pour conclure je
dirais tout simplement monsieur de
beaufort les yeux dans les yeux je crois
que le plus gros reproche qu'on peut
faire à votre ami maurice papon
c'est d'avoir ni remords ni regrets mais
tout est de quoi voudriez vous qu'ils
les remords et regrets parce que il ya
envoyé 1699 pour deux personnes dans les
camps d'extermination et tout le monde
le sait comme dit bernard henri lévy
dans son bloc notes du point il
persévère et ajoute outrage à la douleur
alors il est croyant maurice papon
oui un peu pendant pas énormément va
être énormément croyants comment doit
pas être énormément croyant en soit
écouté je ne sais pas tout à fait il
allait à la messe à la santé il ya un
aumônier catholique qui vient une fois
par semaine et maurice papon insistait
systématiquement à la messe qui était
une qui était dite et demandant là donc
des gens pardon pardon pardon pardon
pardon pardon pardon active dans pardon
aux victimes
non mais il faudrait t'il qui se
considère comme coupable de ces d'avoir
d'avoir emmené ses victimes
n'est ce pas je veux dire s'il est
coupable moi je jeu chargé d'écrire un
livre blanc s'il est coupable je vous
dirais il est coupable
je n'ai aucune sympathie pour les
collaborateurs qui ont collaboré ma
famille qu'est ce que j'ai comme
souvenir moi je vais vous le dire mon
souvenir d'enfance à vous allez en quoi
14-15 ans voilà j'avais 14 15 ans eh
bien il ya un des beaux forts un des
frères beaufort qui est fusillé dans la
propriété par les allemands il est
fusillé par les allemands et les
allemands interdisent compte qu'on
enterre son corps et c'est ma grand-mère
70 ans qui de nuit dans une charrette a
mis le corps sous des faits
go pour aller l'enterrer en catimini
voilà le souvenir que j'ai par
conséquent si pape ont été collaborateur
je vous assure que je ne défendrai pas
moi je vais vous dire une chose c'est
que vous avez mis la mémoire de votre
famille au service d'une bien mauvaise
cause je ne le pense pas tu n'en je le
ferai pas merci berda bof et pour être
sûr de ne rien rater de dinars 10 tubes
abonnez vous il m'était impossible eux